bonjour je m'appelle denis du lamier je
suis d ici à melun où je suis conseiller
départemental du canton de melun depuis
2011 est actuellement vice président du
conseil départemental de seine-et-marne
en charge du logement de l'habitat et de
la politique de la pluie je suis
également un entrepreneur dans
l'agroalimentaire entrepreneurs ici en
seine-et-marne où lui j'ai réussi à
développer un certain nombre de produits
du terroir du territoire pouvoir les
développer compris à l'international en
créant une trentaine d'emplois dans
et bien c'est cette double expérience à
la fois d'entrepreneurs et d'aigus au
contact
associatifs et des habitants je me suis
nourri d'un certain nombre de
problématiques qui problématique sur le
territoire sont aussi les problématiques
ga nous sommes confrontés dans les lois
de ce pays où on a vu dans les cinq ans
pour précéder les 50 premiers mandats de
l'ancien patron des députés hors sol qui
n'avait justement pas cette expérience à
la fois du terrain en tant qu'élu de
l'entrepreneur eh bien je veux être ici
enseignements sur la première subvention
c'est les mandats moulin le candidat de
l'expérience des rangs et aussi courage
courage de faire du courage de porter
les problématiques du territoire mais
aussi le courage d'être à l'assemblée
nationale celui qui votera les lois
lorsqu'elles seront bonnes de pouvoir se
poser à celle qu'une considérons moins
bonne et puis à restaurer aussi
l'autorité les questions du régalien qui
ont été les grandes oubliées des cinq
dernières années la question du handicap
qu'il faut absolument pouvoir aussi
porter haut et fort la question de la
sécurité
que l'immigration pour pouvoir aussi
affronter ce niveau non pas être
confronté à la simple à pratiquer des
extrêmes phase 1 la politique que
monsieur pas de succès ce député qui
souhaitent y être pour couleurs de ma
famille politique celle des républicains
de la droite et du centre pour le calcio
et loyal quel est ce que croit aussi que
ces valeurs de loyauté et de sincérité
de fidélité sont aussi des valeurs de
nos deux vont porter en politique c'est
celle que je porterai vous pouvez faire
confiance sur mon engagement